government officials want to remind you  to not leave the house without a mask as  the city continues to open back up now  in April the CDC began recommending  cloth face coverings or mass in public  we're maintaining social distancing was  going to be difficult the agency cited  recent studies that people can transmit  the virus before showing any symptoms  but now the World Health Organization is  also recommending to cover up it does  provide some measure of protection to me  also although that's smaller mostly on  protecting you and you wearing it  protecting me math need to be worn the  correct way in order to be effective  this is important the nose the mouth and  the chin should be covered and then once  the covering is on trying the mask or  your face or adjusting it